everything you've heard about Leah
that's her real life
you see her on television and she was
acting a certain way but pretty much the
way she is in life
same with Corey
same with Mark the price of Glee pulls
back the curtain on the musical comedy's
behind the scenes drama from Cory
Monteith's struggles ahead of his death
Corey just seemed like he was just
getting more and more neurotic and more
isolating and I just I really didn't
know what was going on with them Talia
Michelle's alleged onset Behavior the
thing is is that no one will ever know
what that experience was like except for
the people that were in the choir room
together
I had a
pretty negative experience with Leah
Michelle first the three-part
documentary dives into Corey's time on
the show he played quarterback turned
Glee Club member Finn I used to think
that this was like the lamest thing on
earth and maybe it is but
we're all here for the same reason
because we want to be good at something
I think we all the resounding answer is
we're excited that a show is finally
going to live up to the hype because we
think it's really good after Corey shot
to fame things spiraled out of control
and his former roommate Justin claims he
struggled with it all amid his sobriety
after his troubled past with drugs and
alcohol he started telling me he's like
it's really hard to like figure out how
to be famous
at one point we had to put extra
security cameras because he had a
stalker
a young girl who was just always falling
in but ahead of filming season five in
2013 Corey died after a drug overdose
during a trip back home to Canada now
prior to his death the actor reportedly
got his hair cut by Doug Kirkpatrick the
head of the show's hair Department most
of the boys came to me for haircuts
after that I left the show and it was
during a haircut that Doug recalled his
chilling final conversation with Corey
in the end at the very last couple days
that I saw him he was different
he was under the influence of alcohol
and so she he said he was at a party and
he hadn't been drinking and he wanted to
have a drink but he knew he shouldn't
and then he was told by a certain cast
member
that same night you know if you want to
have a drink you should have a drink
I'll be here you could always trust that
I will be here for you yeah the hair
stylist claims someone close to Corey
gave him the okay to start drinking
again he started drinking because he was
given permission
by somebody that he loved then there's
Leah who played Rachel Berry and her
alleged behavior on set the greatest
thing about Glee was it taught everyone
to just be who they are and that's what
always made me so proud to be on Glee
the actresses alleged actions were
detailed by cast and crew members
all we hear is from people who were
close to that set actors who tweeted
about being treated mistreated by Leah
Michelle but the only actor to speak out
about it was debier Snell who recalled
an interaction he had with fellow
castmate Darren Chris and Leah during a
break in filming there was lunch and
Darren was like yo you should come by I
was there maybe 10 minutes
and then I got pulled from somebody on
set so she goes somebody specifically at
the table doesn't want you sitting there
it's just the person there just doesn't
feel like you belong with the rest of
the group I took a guess
I said Leah she goes
ET has reached out to Leah's rep for
comment
the price of Glee also includes Mark
sealing who played Puck it's fun to play
the jerk you know and you don't have to
make them likeable and accessible so but
it's a lot of fun after appearing in all
six seasons Mark was arrested in 2015 on
suspicion of possessing child
pornography and eventually pleaded
guilty in 2018 he was found dead by
Suicide before he could be formally
sentenced a former set decorator on Glee
says Mark knew how severe his situation
was
no you can't bounce back from that and I
think he knew that the news came as a
shock to those who worked with him the
crew recalled Mark as an introverted and
professional guy he was quieter
for sure
he just was you know a bit off
it was sort of hard to hear some of the
things that would ultimately come out it
was just like wait what now I will say
in in full disclosure
usually people are on their best
behavior once they get around the crew
none of this cast chose to participate
in the docu-series in fact many have
publicly slammed it
it doesn't matter what happened on that
set at the end of the day it's a family
it's like a big dysfunctional family and
there's a loyalty there like mob
mentality where I'm like I don't care
how much I hated this person at work
there's something that runs so deep in
my blood that I could hate you so much
but I don't hate you enough I don't hate
us enough to go do that I think all
that's bull I think it's a little bit of
like
trying to get people to watch something
but despite the show's tragedies some of
the Glee Stars remain close I went to
New York to see Darren's show and then
me and Darren kicked it in Nashville
like a couple weeks after and I see you
I see Darren all the time uh got lunch
with Harry Jenna lives across the street
from one of my best friends and so I see
her all the time and then run into Kevin
at the gym and I know I kind of see them
all whenever you know whenever I can it
was just one of those things where it
just felt like its own weird family to
where it was like I'm as I I'm as close
to all those people like whenever I see
them as you know we left off and it's
like it's almost like times times time
kind of stands still with that
foreign